hi everyone there's a lot going on with
russia and ukraine so we thought we'd
jump on to answer a few questions and
help you get your head around to the
basics starting with
what just happened
so on monday russia's president vladimir
putin officially recognized two
breakaway areas in eastern ukraine both
of them are in the donbass region they
call themselves the people's republics
of luhansk and donetsk and they've been
controlled by pro-russian separatists
since 2014 with russia's backing now
these so-called people's republics make
up around one-third of the ukrainian
districts of luhansk and donetsk and
there's what's called a line of control
with the separatists on one side and the
ukrainian forces on the other they've
been fighting each other off and on
across that line for years even though
they're supposed to be a ceasefire
one thing to keep in mind is that the
separatists lay claim to all of luhansk
and donetsk not just the one-third they
control now and putin confirmed that
russia's recognition of the independence
of these so-called people's republics
also includes their claim to that extra
territory now president putin made
another big move he's ordered russian
soldiers to go into the separatist areas
he says they're peacekeepers we've been
speaking to people inside the
self-declared republic of donetsk they
were describing the russian military
buildup as being like nothing they'd
seen before they described tanks
grad missile systems so this is a really
big deal
because it raises the risk of a direct
confrontation between russian and
ukrainian forces and that could trigger
something even bigger maybe a full-blown
war
don't forget russia looks ready for one
it's been building up troops along
ukraine's border for months the us
reckons there are now up to 190 000
soldiers surrounding ukraine on three
sides everything from of course the
high-end
weapon systems to field hospitals to
logistics
to commander controls okay so next
question why did putin make this move in
eastern ukraine well you can answer that
on a few different levels there's the on
the ground stuff
[Music]
putin says russian speakers and russian
citizens living in eastern ukraine have
been under attack all these years by
ukrainian forces and they need
protection and recently separatist
leaders started evacuating people to
russia they accused ukraine of planning
a military operation to retake the
territories
but ukraine rejects that accusation and
the u.s nato and others think putin has
just been cooking up an excuse to go in
president putin made a series of
outrageous false claims about ukraine
aimed at creating a pretext for war and
immediately thereafter announced russian
troops are entering the donbas he calls
them peacekeepers
this is nonsense
we know what they really are so why
might putin be willing to consider a war
well that takes us to the other thing
he's been talking about a lot nato the
western military alliance and what he
feels is an intolerable threat to
russian security
putin has basically been telling nato to
get out of his neighborhood he wants
guarantees that it will never admit
ukraine is a member and stop any further
expansion to the east
nato says it will never agree to that
that ukraine is a sovereign country and
that it's not for russia to decide even
though it's pretty unlikely that ukraine
would join nato anytime soon
but here's another thing when putin
announced russia's recognition of the
breakaway areas he gave a long rambling
speech complete with his own take on
history which included the idea that
ukraine is part of ancient russian lands
he essentially questioned the whole
legitimacy of ukraine as an independent
country
the speech by
president putin the 65 minute long
diatribe many ellis have said it's a
declaration of war he's not invading
because it's not a sovereign country
that's his narrative okay so next
question what's the response been
well from ukraine and the west outrage
basically ukraine
who in the lord's name does putin think
gives them the right to declare
new so-called countries
on territory that belong to his
neighbors
this is a flagrant violation of
international law this is the most
dangerous moment in european security
for a generation and what are they doing
about it
well for a while now western countries
have been sending weapons and money to
ukraine and they've beefed up troop
numbers in nearby nato countries places
like poland romania and the baltic
states and now they're hitting russia
with economic sanctions targeting people
and organizations connected to the
decision to recognize the breakaway
areas and with links to russia's
military so for example wealthy
individuals politicians and some banks
germany's made a big move by suspending
the final approval for nordstream 2 a
major gas pipeline from russia which has
already been built and western leaders
say they've got even tougher sanctions
ready to go if they need them something
in reserve in case putin goes further
because to recognize these two republics
he didn't need more than 150 000 troops
and many fear that there is another
stage
to his operations okay so final question
how are ukrainians feeling about all
this well of course it depends on who
you ask and where they live some people
are scared but many ukrainians also seem
to be getting on with life as best they
can people are remarkably calm actually
and since this whole crisis kicked off
they've been incredibly stoic in their
response and it kind of runs really
counter to the panic that has been
splashed across western
headlines i think there is a kind of
level up of panic but i think it's still
so unclear about what's going to happen
so it's so hard to prepare when you
don't know what you're preparing for um
[Music]
that's crazy because we don't want to
water
that's the thing with this crisis it's
not new but it's definitely gone up
another notch now if you were hoping for
answers to the biggest questions in all
this
what does putin really want and how far
is he willing to go
well there's really only one person who
can answer that
remember if you want more basics and
background info on things like the roots
of the conflict and the donbass region
and why russia has beef with nato then
check out our earlier episode linked
here and if you're looking for all the
latest updates you can follow the live
blog on aljazeera.com see you next week
you